did you guys do you guys feel the same
way you know my parents always told me
you know when you go to university
that's where you grow up that's
that's you know that's how that's that's
what they said
yeah yeah because that's where you're
like treated as an adult
right right with responsibility and
stuff but anyone who's still in
university
is such a warped experience of what
adult life is like
yeah you know what i mean it's i yeah
because i guess university is kind of
like the ramp
to being an adult the way i saw it like
there was people there who left
university who i'm like you
you should not be living alone you
cannot take care of yourself
and then there's other people who i'm
like yeah you know they'd be fine you
know like
i feel i feel like if you can't take
care of yourself at uni you're really
going to have a hard time taking
yourself after uni as well we've
definitely met those people
like half people i lived with were like
incapable like one of them was like a
serial gambler and like lost all his
money
and like one of my friends was the same
yeah he one one time he
won 10k 10k for uni students
in a casino that's insane which is
insane basically millionaire yeah yeah
yeah you're basically a [ __ ]
millionaire and everyone's like
no [ __ ] way you won that much he lost
it within two weeks
two weeks because he was so addicted to
gambling
it's it's [ __ ] insane oh gosh i asked
him so how could you spend that much you
could have paid off your student loans
and everything yeah and i remember
him just saying oh because it just
didn't mean anything to me
because that was like a guy in
the house next to me the one that got
pooped in um
as you gentlemen know as we all know and
he was like
basically like a neo-nazi and he was
really [ __ ] weird
and he would always come over and bring
like two
40 year old woman and and he was like
having threesomes with them both
and he would exclusively refer to them
as like sugar tits
like did he like time travel from the
50s
and he was like and i remember one time
because my friend
give me a sugar tits so yeah he was like
he's literally like
my friend was telling me he was like
yeah it's it's really weird he was like
mixing chemicals in his room and i was
like
bro tell the [ __ ] university people
what do you mean he's mixing chemicals
in this room you're really you're really
doing a good job like selling on whales
yeah like this where'd you go again no
no i don't want to
name the university in case they get
really mad at me but
bristol university represents sydney
union you can find out what university
it's not that hard it's somewhere out
there yeah he was always that guy
who was like you know when like someone
would talk about a fight they were like
well if i had my glock there it would be
over
you know what i mean and you're like
what
what do you mean like come again it's
just that those guys are like yeah i
know to use gun
it's like yeah a gun would fix that yeah
always and it's like he like talks about
guns too much
he he brought up like mine camp like
uncomfortable
like an uncomfortable amount of time
right like i remember
my favorite piece of literature he was
like
i remember one time it's like his excuse
for not doing an
assignment was because he was too
in-depth into reading about nazi history
and how interesting it was and like
that's always like a double-edged sword
when they're telling like a red flag
yeah yeah it's like are you interested
in or like interested yeah
are you like this sounds like an episode
of peep shows
you luckily never had to deal with it my
friend did yeah
apparently one time uh he he
my friend who was telling me all this
had borrowed something from the the
neo-nazi character
yeah and um he it was in his room and
his his room was locked
and so this guy didn't want to wait 30
minutes to do it
so he just took all the bolts off his
door with like a screwdriver set and
just removed the door and went in
and never gave him his like door back
like the stuff
but like two weeks before the university
came and fixed it the dude had no door
and he had like a gaming pc and
everything like the dude just had no
door
the front door to this bungalow was
always left open
there's like there's there's taking you
know like utensils
yeah and then there's taking a door he
like took
the like the door like with all the like
the what the [ __ ]
handle all the hinges he just took it
off and just removed the door to like
the side like it's like a caveman with a
stone entrance
like um my keys or something whatever it
was and
you just did like this dude was insane
he was the kind of guy who like when
you're around him for five minutes
you're like i don't want to be around
you anymore
you've said too many uncomfortable
things in five minutes and when he
brought his two
40 year old woman girlfriends around
like that disgusting get them out of my
house
his sugar tits yeah he's so gross
i was like 20 like cleaning my dishes
like what the [ __ ] is happening